and now
Brandon six
boy
sh well good morning kids we are not
live today your boy has back to back to
back pods so we're kicking this one off
early on this rainy rainy ass Monday it
is boring here in Los Angeles uh flood
warnings all up in the news uh the
studio here is is wet whenever it rains
it gets wet the Ste gets wet it's a
problem we complain they don't care so
we got to take our equipment home that's
just the way it goes it rains studio is
going to get wet but as my dad says
whenever there's rain we need
it that's what Dad say man we need it um
glad to have you guys thanks for tuning
in um we're just building up to the big
UFC 29 was it 7 98 98 298 that's all
we're waiting for you have a pretty
pretty tasty Fight Night way better than
last week's last Saturday's fight night
this fight night is pretty tasty but
this episode of the shop show on this
rainy morning is brought to you by the
one the only DraftKings and if you're
looking for a super offer from superball
58 look no further my friends at
draftking Sportsbook got you covered new
customers can bet on the big game and
turn five bucks into 200 instantly in
bonus bets I like to do the prop bets
myself uh you can do Christian mcaffrey
over 75 yards uh more than one touchdown
uh KD scoring a touchdown I like to play
those games and they can also bet on
Patrick Mahomes over 250 yards I like to
Parlay those instead of just betting on
one team makes the games funner to watch
so if you're down to make some buckaroos
and watch the Super Bowl download the
draftking Sportsbook app right now use
the code shop show Au show new customers
can bet five bucks to get 200 instantly
in bonus bets only on draftking
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the Super Bowl 58 with the
code shop show the crown is
yours gambling problem call 1800 Gambler
or in West Virginia visit www.1 1800
gambler. net in New York call 8778 heny
or text Hope
n46 7369 in Connecticut help is
available for problem gambling call
888878 9777 7 or visit ccpg dorg please
play responsibly on behalf of booill
Casino and Resort in Kansas 21 plus age
varies by jurisdiction void in Ontario
bonus bets expire 1068 hours after
issuance see dk.com for eligibility and
deposit restriction terms and
responsible gaming resources yes I like
the energy case the energy Casey's been
a a little sick yeah me Casey had to
carpool today like some adults car
pooling dude in case you had to pick me
up from the crib yeah I was like don't
you have more cars than anybody I know
how come you need a ride your boy's an
idiot and um waiting to get the TRX back
we should have news on that this week so
that was the Dad mobile in the rain and
every other thing out here and my other
two cars have race slicks on them
because I'm a [__] I like to drive fast
but race Saks can't go in the rain so
you can't drive so uh Papa need a ride
this morning car pulled it was nice yeah
you like the Jetta though you like my J
I dig the Jetta Quality Car
reliable I grew up in a Jetta my aunt
nby had a Jetta to pick me up from
school so it brings back good memories
they're safe
reliable you know it's just you know
isn't Volkswagen Porsche too are they
they own Porsche yeah something like
that yeah Volkswagen owns uh I mean a
ton of it yeah so you're saying I
basically have a Porsche basically is
that saying CH basically sure same thing
little different Toyota Lexus yeah yeah
same thing um fight week wise
the biggest news would be um not in the
MMA World be in the boxing World Tyson
Fury has suffered a cut over his right
eye which tends to happen to Fighters
that for their job one of the
requirements is you Spar and get punched
in the face and sometimes this
happens now I find it fascinating but
just the way the world Works people
think tym Fury did this on
purpose you know how stupid you have to
be to think Tyson
Fury the best box on planet Earth
purposely cut himself and when you think
about this let's go through the
logistics of this so you think he took a
knife and took it to his right eye and
cut himself that is insane he is a
multi-time world champion um
undefeated and uh he has no reason to be
that scared of usk that is absolutely
bonkers
and if if it was on the other end if
usyk was the guy who did this then the
Tyson Fury fans like oh you just don't
want to fight him you're scared there's
nothing worse when people say this
fighter scared of insert this fighter
that is ridiculous that is not the case
that's fun it's fun it'll get your
clicks it'll get the people going but
it's all just noise of course Tyson fur
expected
this you see this it's like oh just say
you're scared already okay
yeah Tyson Fury scared of another man in
boxing so he does for a job it's just
it's something to say if you don't like
him he gives you something to you know
do for the day to hate on Tyson Fury but
just it's so amateur it's just so stupid
so stupid he looked like he was in
phenomenal shape too yeah and so he was
apparently cut by an elbow during
sparring so which is weird cuz the
footage they show he stops it there I
didn't see the elbow did you yeah in the
slow motion you can kind of see slicing
he tells him right away like stop it
yeah oh I okay right here slow-mo oh a
straight elble yeah damn he does say
stop damn dog say't more
Tha um yeah that's a bot happens it
sucks the fight's pushed to may they
said May May 10th I think but uh May 18
18 yeah this is interesting uh because
they had a a clause in place anybody
that pulls out has to pay $10 million in
penalty fees yeah the adviser for Saudi
Arabia I wonder if he's going to hold
his feet to the fire with that you know
I want but are they just going to take
you out of his purse out of his50 $60
million purse which is a big yeah which
is weird because I could understand if
he pulled out due to un you know some
random stuff like I'm just not ready or
you know this or but a cut and we have
video of the cut how can you fault the
guy what are you going to do would you
rather have him fight and then the fight
gets stopped in the second round due to
the blood running into his eyes and he
almost got stopped before by the other
guy Wallen remember it was like super he
got cut and it stopped yeah it's an
issue and Ariel hanani is the one that
actually um did like in he broke the
yeah last minute like interview with
them so yeah that was dope yeah but the
fight just gets pushed to May which is
better you said for better for Fury yeah
now do I think he was going to fight
next weekend absolutely is it better if
you're a fury fan to got pushed sh yeah
although he looks like phenomenal shape
for him phenomenal
shape yeah he looks good there small leg
but he's a giant
though yeah he's a
giant and Francis tweeted was like so
does that mean me vers Joshua's for the
Undisputed Championship it's like no and
that's his meme that he did which is
pretty funny that's
hilarious so me and Joshua for the
Undisputed title March 8th that's
hilarious yeah and he used that Kevin
James meme that's been like blowing up
like crazy lately that's
great
what else you got Jen oh let's uh want
to cover the fights that just happened
over the last yeah did you watch these I
did yeah some uh I mean some some fun
Knockouts your boy Randy Brown did work
and then Molly got the armar and the 50k
bonus yeah good for her man I'm a fan of
her uh she needed that win so bad but um
yeah your boy
rato
uh he's so funny dude yeah he's
interesting yeah his dad got he has a
little brother coming yeah at 62 years
old he impregnated his I guess
girlfriend wife or whatever yeah yeah
the main event was interesting it was
imol with the eye pokes the headbutts
the legal kicks yeah he did beat the
breaks off Roman
though uh Chris Curtis you you saw that
in the middle of the round one rounds
like they were going back and forth
involving Chris Critters talking stuff
to each other yeah and Chris posted that
four eye pokes two headbutts and kicking
a down opponent what a time to be alive
yeah it's tough Chris and him went to
like a no contest because of a headbutt
issue
prior but yeah and but that girl that
got her arm snapped by uh Molly mccan
apparently there's no broken bones but
there's uh most likely torn ligaments I
don't know if you've ever experienced
torn ligaments and how bad they I've had
uh like stretch ligaments never torn in
the arm that's M but yeah usually I mean
the Frank May Tim Sylvia fight you see a
broken arm usually the yeah the MRI
wouldn't show a broken bone it's the
ligaments are torn and it you're going
to have fast recovery if you break the
bone the ligaments is way worse oh snap
yeah it's going to take way long she me
that sucks good news no broken bone I
have to do MRI as soon as I get back
into Canada feels like a torn ligament
yeah that's not good have you ever
popped an elbow from like an arm I've
hyperextended it yeah it takes a hot
second to come
back yeah you almost prefer the broken
bone if I if it's complete torn ligament
yeah it's if it's completely torn they
still have to get the MRI but yeah we'll
see what happens depend how the brone
bone breaks if it's like a spiral
fracture you
know then you have to do a major surgery
but if it's just like a clean break or
minor break then I'd much prefer that
than a torn
ligament yeah the fights were good so
that thba guy that The Rock bought a
house for yeah yeah he's still killing
it yep he did seconds yeah not a great
fight night this week's this Saturday's
fight night's a lot better the main
event's tasty for sure Hermanson versus
pyer pyer yeah yeah and even though
Piper's not ranked he's favored in that
fight I would pick him as well he's a
Savage yeah Dan eay Andre f is a
phenomenal fight fight yeah Brad Tavarez
and the Brazilian rooc cop Brad's
Underdog in that which is weird Michael
Johnson dearest flowers that's a fun one
holfo and petan great the main car is
fun I'll take it all freaking day this
is back at the Apex huh people hate the
Apex I mean the one good thing about it
is it starts earlier usually which is
better for us to watch so 4 PM PST but
yeah it's not as fun to watch I don't
think it sucks for the fighters too some
like it I don't know yeah I mean it's
it's easier for the UFC to pull off
right they control everything it's just
easier but I think like 40% of their
fights at the Apex now really yeah but I
mean so I would
imagine I mean it's not a huge card but
you would want ticket sales from a gate
too right UFC is good I think they like
no we're good cuz think about the
production cost is way lower at the Apex
they're not renting a facility they
don't have to have all everything's
already in place they're not paying all
the production the hotels I'm you know
it's in Vegas they own a ton of hotels
or they have set up there you have all
the Medicals so the cost is so much
lower for them yeah well there you go so
I bet it it outweighs the the price of
traveling
40% and remember this was all set up
just during covid lockdowns so they
could keep on keeping on so you're proud
of the UFC that they figured out a way
to give us entertainment during
lockdowns during Co when no other league
was performing but then they're the only
League that hasn't adapted after the the
lockdowns are over they're continuing to
do what they did during
lockdowns so it's good and bad the great
thing is they found a way to continue on
and the league kept going and the the we
got the fights we got entertainment
during Co the bad news is they're still
doing it there's no crowd there's no
energy it doesn't feel like a big fight
night you know I heard your boy Joe
Rogan always saying like he likes it
better because you can hear you know
everything and it's just more like you
know but he never
fought I'm saying as a fan as a fan if
you're there you know if you're there
there's no there's no I don't give a I
mean it's a fun thing to say that you're
telling me that you would rather hear
the corner and hear the smack of the
Fist hitting the face opposed to a sold
out Mt Square Garden Conor McGregor walk
out the energy in that freaking Arena
it's not even comparable it's just not
it's and you're talking about apples and
oranges like I I think for the Dana
White Contender series that's perfect
it's not as much pressure you're used to
that it makes sense easy production but
for some big Main Events like taiu ofasa
I think they're they're doing a they did
a main event there that's insane like a
heavyweight fight ranked in top 10 come
on man but again it's just it's for the
UFC it's easy from a business aspect I
get it but it just I think it sucks for
the fighters no one's going to say that
you know uh most Fighters do say that
though they do say like they want the
the the no you want to feeler of the
crowd but you also want to feel like
you're in the big leagues like can you
imagine the NFL was like Hey for the
Rams game we're just going to do at the
complex here we're going to do at The
Practice Facility only seats 300 people
like this the players like this sucks it
feels like a
scrimmage yeah it's better for us
production value all
right I'm curious what their views are
like on those Apex yeah what if the
views are lower
too I'll take a look in a bit um so
during that fight Dana White was also in
Las Vegas so instead of attending the
UFC he attended the boxing match hell
yeah hell yeah in Vegas that's how you
know he's like what con Ben versus Peter
do it it's a there's a he's like there's
40 of these there's only one toone
boxing match you know so and he wants to
get into boxing so but I mean as a as a
now he's the what he's a CEO now not not
the president he's a CEO right but yeah
but imagine if you're the fighter like
you want Dana like I know that's like
you're The Ultimate Fighter if Dana
wasn't there you're so bummed out can
you show up to certain days and when he
was there like you got to put on a show
so if you're if you're one of these
fighters on the fight night like hey
here's the thing not only are you not
getting the big fight experience but
also Dana went to a boxing match instead
that's how you know it's like it's a
fight
night yeah it's almost like amateur
League to the big leagues you know so
apparently he's been meeting with Eddie
Hearn and then um I saw this he's
meeting K ktie Taylor here as well and
then I ALS o saw a post recently
where David Felman from bkfc met up with
Dana White and he posted a big meeting
today with Dana White so he's meeting
with all these other like I don't know
if they're necessarily A like you know
competitors but he's meeting with these
guys that are doing different streams
and yeah yeah I mean Eddie Eddie Hearn
doesn't need Dana White you know and I
would I would think this David Feldman
needs Dana you know but that's the
difference in the meetings um and you
know Conor's been at the bkfc events
like multiple times Mike Perry's the
face of it I think it's smart for David
because it's not there's no competition
there and it is a different product I
could see them buying or partnering up
with bear knuckle to bring it to Fight
Pass oh okay because the more content
they get right yeah and then also
obviously the WWE they sold which is
crazy was it five billion to Netflix but
that's just for one I think it's I don't
know the difference but there's it's for
the WWE Raw series which is one show so
that'd be like the UFC selling just the
Apex fights to Netflix for5 billion and
then the pay-per-views are
separate so they're not getting like
WrestleMania on there they're not
getting you know the the other the
Smackdown or what the hell it's called
they're only getting raw or Smackdown I
forget which one but they're only
getting one of those shows the rest of
them are a different platform so they're
making money elsewhere too so that'd be
like the UFC selling just the fight
nights to Netflix for 5 billion and then
the rest of the cards on another Network
yeah so it is raw it's raw yeah booah so
um for five billion that's what's
interesting because I mean wrestling
does the same things because you know
they're not like but just so you guys
know like the NFL the MLB the NBA when
they signed like whatever it is that $20
billion licensing TV deal that goes back
to the players they get 50% of that
because there's no licensed deal if the
players don't play so for the fighters
like with this lawsuit coming up I think
it's right after UFC 300 one of the
arguments should be like now is the time
to do it fellas rally the troops if you
want I'm out I don't have a dog in this
fight but now would be the time to say
we're not fighting anymore until we get
a percentage of the TV rights because
they're negotiating the UFC is
negotiating right now probably with
Netflix Netflix wants live sports cuz
that's the future of everything right
only live sports gets all the ratings so
Netflix wants it
X wants it YouTube wants it Amazon wants
it so all the big dogs want these live
sports UFC is a live sport so they're
negotiating right now if I'm a big name
in the UFC I'm rallying other big names
going hey here's our opportunity because
otherwise we got to wait another five
six years which most of them will be no
not competing or in their Prime won't be
the same Stars so now would be the time
go hey guys Now's the Time
we pull all the stops and go no no no
we're not fighting unless we get a
percentage of the TV
deal because it's going to be billions
of dollars we want a percentage of that
that goes towards the fighters the NBA
NFL's 50% you're not g 50% 10% would be
a huge
increase you know yeah you don't think
that'll ever happen though right it
won't happen but I'm just saying Now's
the Time to do it now is the perfect
opportunity to go whoa whoa whoa they're
they're negotiating TV writes let's see
if we can get a piece of this pie
here they won't do it it'd be but now's
the time now is the time while they're
negotiating when the deal's done you're
screwed Now's the Time cuz the networks
going like hold on dude we're not going
to commit to anything till you figure
out with these Fighters sounds like the
fighters aren't going to fight unless
you give them percentage Yeah so they
would all have to somehow come together
all yeah which ain't happening yeah it's
not going to happen no it's too
difficult but it's too many moving
pieces but they could now would be the
time to do it more so than ever while
these TV they're figuring out the TV
right deals right now and maybe it's not
you know maybe it's just a 10 or 15%
increase in everybody's salary across
the board they can do that but think
about it us is going to sell off their
TV rights for billions of dollars the
fighters get
nothing does that seem fair to you nope
nope of course not no not at all ain't
no way you can do [__] though it's just
an
idea I'll tell you who's doing stuff
though my friend said O'Reilly
o oh O'Reilly bonus points Mar month at
O'Reilly Auto Part shop in store online
to receive points and get rewards sent
straight to your phone or inbox get two
three four even five times bonus points
on select purchases receive bonus points
on select items throughout the store
like wiper blades anti-freeze coolant
partch cleaner motor oil and more I was
just at O'Reilly's this past weekend
trying to file down this freaking thing
uh on the intake of my lightning because
it doesn't fit so I'm literally just
cutting this metal piece out I spend
hours on it and apparently um my my boy
r at kib Tech has a machine that just
can do it in second so that's good to
know um but shout out to Ori for getting
me the part they know exactly what I
need these bonus points can help you get
to your next reward even faster you
receive $5 reward for every 150 o reward
points to use on your next in store or
online purchase members can check points
and rewards online anytime you feel if
if you are already an o o Rewards member
and not receiving your rewards just add
an email address or mobile phone number
you get $10 reward for updating your
existing account if you're not an o o
Rewards member yet signning up is super
easy and quick online at O'Reilly
auto.com or in store at O'Reilly Auto
Parts o
O'Reilly Progressive back to back cool
Chen this episode the shop show on this
rainy Monday is also brought to you by
Progressive Auto
Insurance hey y'all whether you love
true crime or comedy celebrity
interviews news or even motivational
speakers you call the shots on what's in
your podcast queue right what you decide
to listen to guess what now you can call
the shots on your auto insurance too
enter the Name Your Price tool from
Progressive the Name Your Price tool
puts you in charge of your auto
insurance by working just the way it
sounds you tell Progressive how much you
want to pay for a car Insurance they'll
show you a variety of coverages that
will fit within your budget giving you
so many options now that's something you
want to press play on it's easy to start
a quote and you'll be able to choose the
best option for you it's fast it's just
one of the many ways you can save with
Progressive Insurance quote today at
progressive.com to try the Name Your
Price tool for yourself join the over 28
million drivers who trust Progressive
Progressive Casualty Insurance Company
Affiliates price and coverage match
limited by state law auto insurance
super important dealing with it now
they take forever though it takes they
take their sweet
time we just had a insurance adjuster
come look at my truck goes yep it's
total I know you drove all the way down
there for that we told you that he goes
yeah had to see it for my own see it
with my own peepers like cool man what
now he goes I'll go back and I'll report
it and then we'll take it from there I'm
like okay dude 3 weeks wait for that
hell yeah dude I can't drive in the rain
till you get this figured out Cas you
going have to keep picking me up pick
them up pick them up replace your tires
without slicks
never I need slicks chin to go fast when
it's sunny
out okay well uh sha Brady was supposed
to fight vente luk it was canceled but
then the reason why I bring this up is
because remember the other cancellation
or almost cancellation with Dustin
porier and Ben Beno St Den um
apparently um Shan Brady said that the
contract was actually never really
signed and plus he was injured anyway
yeah he didn't he never signed it to do
anything but this is just a tactic by
the UFC they've been doing this since
I've been around the game it's just one
of you can call it a bullying tactic a
business tactic however you want to do
it but the UFC will announce the fight
without informing the fighter and they
wake up to the news of it like benois St
Denise said he woke up in the middle of
night was like oh dang I'm fighting
Dusen por he had no idea his wife woke
him up he started laughing she's like
hey they just announced your fight he's
like what so he didn't he was down
obviously but he didn't know so the this
is one of the tactics the US will use
just how you guys know how the hot dog's
made here they will do this so it puts
the pressure on the fighter so now if
poier uh Shawn Brady if they pull out
it's on it makes them look bad so they
it's just another way the UFC puts
pressure on the this the fight we want
we've already announced it if you pull
out it's going to look really bad and
most Fighters go I don't want that and
they commit to horrible matchups
so Dustin por because he's a living
legend and has all the credibility goes
H it ain't happening unless you back up
the Brin trucks it's not happening so
there's a dispute on his fee and they
didn't want to pay it and he's like all
right well I never signed this or agreed
to it y'all so that's why he decided to
go public with and go hold up never
agreed to this this isn't for sure I'm
not fighting him the UFC then now this
this is the way it can backfire but you
have to be at a Dustin po Conor McGregor
Izzy level Strickland level where you
can go nope not agreed until you pay me
this and then the UFC's like oh we've
already announced it we better pay him
so this time it backfired on the UFC
they paid Dustin por now we get the
fight we want to
see but yeah for Sean Brady's like dude
I'm not even healthy this is insane why
would I and it wasn't even signed so
yeah I mean that's something it seems
like a tactic that they've been doing it
it's very it's a very Joe Silva way of
doing things did they ever make you do
that
uh they announced I forget which fight
might have been
they they were going to announce it and
then something happened with him I was
supposed to fight uh Stephan stru and
what the yep and I got a call and
they're like fighting Stephan stro and I
was like wait and they hung up the phone
like okay guess that's happening and
then literally 5 minutes later something
was true was was happening I it was they
call like you're fight MCO crocop I was
like oh that's even better
but I remember I was hitting mits with
my coach like this cuz he's so tall I
was like all right here we go we'll
figure this out 7 foot and then
literally they the coach Came in Like H
on we just got a call from Dana fighting
Crow cop I'm like all right bring those
back down here let's work on head
kicks but they do it all the time it's
just a way to put pressure on the
fighters so they feel obligated to take
the
fight but I I don't know what it's going
to take for fighters to have you know to
come together and like now's the perfect
time again I'm it I'm not saying it's
going to happen but if the fighters are
listening dudes and ladies like now is
the time while they're going through the
TV rights this is when you put your foot
in the sand and say hold up we know
you're negotiating for billions of
dollars we want a piece of it otherwise
nobody is fighting I guarantee you
something would get done I guarantee
you'd get more money guarantee
it you just would all have to do it from
from the first fight in the prelim to
the main event if you all do it where
they can't make money and then sponsors
like hey man you promised this it puts
so much pressure on the UFC you're going
to get some part of that big TV
deal yeah it seems like the big big
Fighters obviously Connor Jon Jones all
those guys they probably wouldn't do it
but what if everyone underneath them no
even them why why wouldn't Conor do it I
don't know Conor con set no Conor's what
look what Conor does at the UFC he gets
him by the ball he do the hell saying
that's saying he'd be if I guarantee it
if all it's really it's on the managers
if every manager in the game called all
his Fighters here's the deal we're going
for a chunk of this TV deal it's going
to be billions of dollars if we can just
get 10% your purse will go up by
10% you just have to hold their feet to
the fire we're not quitting they're good
it's going to it's going to get a little
rough but within a month I guarantee you
we get some sort of money but everyone
has to be on board so the managers from
the to
manager to the low level manager it gets
low in MMA if all of them do it the
fighter like all right and then the
fighters go that's what manager saying
to do put on the manager let Dana hate
the managers let them be the bad guy
like managers should be like when
someone comes to me with a deal I always
go yeah let's do it man talk to my
manager my manager like this is a
terrible idea he's he's the [__] not
me I I say yes to everything the manager
filters it that's what a manager should
do so for the
Fighters we don't know man MRE says
we're not fighting till you guys figure
something out I I want to fight they're
telling me they're not going to
negotiate until we get a deal that's how
it should go but of course it won't
happen I mean it' be so hard for so much
more money for the fighters in the long
run like if Mano hey your bills and
stuff we cover for two months while we
get this figured out every because if
you think in the grand scheme of things
everyone's going to make more money in
the long run everybody the managers the
fighters everybody
that does seem like a good route do you
know and for the UFC with the lawsuit if
they go nah we just gave them a bunch of
money portion of the TV deal so what are
you talking about it's a win-win for
everybody UFC UFC would notice whatever
how much biling we get from uh your
experience do managers usually like are
they cool with each other like if it's a
different opponent you know just working
out are they usually cool with each
other yeah most of them are cool yeah so
that that' be a great route then yeah
yeah you get all the big dog managers in
the
room but you're you're obviously going
to have the scabs you
know scabs but then Dana's going to
realize that the brand isn't what he
thinks it is you need the stars because
I'm Dana's ego right away like all right
we just get the scabs in there guys who
wanted to fight who were foaming at the
mouth to fight get them in sign a six
fight deal we'll still put on the fight
nights and then they realize oh no
nobody's tuning in then advertisers go
hey man you promis these ratings oh no
they're starting to back out oh no we
have to pay
them yeah like Now's the Time fellas and
during the negotiations right and it's
going on right now and they have to the
end of the year but you don't want to
wait till that deal sign and then like
no sorry would would I promise we do on
the next one in six years if you're 30
okay I'll be probably done what are you
talking about yeah what else you got all
right so this is uh Jake Paul fighting
another person that honestly I don't
think any of any of us have even heard
of but he's a tougher dude no I'm pretty
familiar with Ryan burland you might be
but I'm saying for the average person
I've saw I've seen all his
fights he's had two-year layoff two-year
layoff 17 and two but Jake Paul man you
know say what you want about him I know
he's not fighting Canelo this guy's this
he's just dude he's taking the the path
like he's doing what Young Fighters
should be doing at a boxing level
without his Fame like fighting these
unknown tough guys
for him like nobody's watching this
really his hardcores are we w't him
watch it here I mean I love the kid but
you know no one's stopping what they're
doing and watching this Jake Paul fight
this Ryan cat so would it be easier for
him to fight a a Mike Perry or a Luke
rockold or someone in that MMA space
where you get the audience and people
are tuning in of course he could do that
all day the next 10 fights he can do
that there's enough MMA retired guys
that he could get out of fight fighting
and do that and make way more money get
more way more eyeballs no matter how you
feel about Jake Paul you've got to
respect what he's doing absolutely he's
making less money tougher fights
nobody's watching he's still put in the
work it's wild right dude that's super D
and all he wants and I don't he'll never
get it I I've told him this in person he
will never get the the credit he
deserves never he could knock out Canelo
tomorrow and still oh lucky shot no one
will give him credit so I don't know
what he's going for I don't know
maybe I'd love to talk to his manager
about like what's the goal here what
you're you're doing what a a a normal
boxer would do you're doing what a boxer
who's broke has another job with do
right now you're going
backwards like yeah we want to make him
a legit boxer maybe he wants to be
ranked you know the WBO wbco whatever it
is it seems like he legit wants to be
considered a real professional boxer
which is so admirable I think it's never
happening I I respect him I I think is a
legit boxer but as far as like the
boxing heads giving him validation
that's never happening for to it's never
happening that's what he wants like d
it's not happening unless he destroys I
don't know why you care it's prize
fighting you want to fight guys in that
ring you make the most money possible
you want to fight the easiest most
famous opponent you were doing it
perfectly and all of a sudden the
criticism oh you're fighting these
washed up okay how many millions are you
making I think with him though he's
already so successful and he has enough
money where I think he is really putting
himself to the test which is admirable I
think it's awesome that he's actually
doing this it's pretty cool obviously he
should make more money that that'd be
the best route but if he's doing this
that's pretty badass yeah good no it's
how you don't respect it is wild to me
yeah and that fight is like uh
apparently March
2nd uh it's in Puerto Rico so that's
where he
lives
second
okay you know okay 172 Pro like okay
wild tough fight for him the they oh the
guy's two years off okay still that's a
straight up boxer that's all that kid
does and all I do is use happy hippo
listen I only recommend products I use
personally on this show this is one
sponsor I reached out to cuz me and Chin
more chin all we do is use cra Adam we
only use it from one trusted Source
we're talking about happy hippo I use it
all the time podcast standup workouts
whatever I'm doing and my kids baseball
games your boy Sauced up on cam all
right helps me tackle my busy ass
schedule it's the best way to describe
it it's not like an energy drink where
you have all this energy it get you more
it gets me in the zone it gets me in a
good feeling good Zone feeling that's
what it does for me my favorite are the
highly highly concentrated shots they
have Taffy they got gun
they got everything the powders if you
just want to mix it with stuff um they
got the K dips where if you want to do
it like you use nicotine you can do that
as well and you can get 20% off all you
got to do is go to happy hippo promo
code is thick with three C's 24 you get
20% off for life of the best creatum on
mother planet
Earth and last one
caged oh boy my favorite supplement ever
again I reached out to these cats turn a
lot of people down I was with another
suppl company for literally forever
since I was a kid and then boom I got
hooked on this pre-workout before I was
working out I'm like what is this and
then one of my buddies like you know
they have a mindset as well I'm like
what's that they're like it's like uh a
neut Tropic with caffeine it will blow
your brains out literally will make you
feel like you're on the Limitless pill I
said tell me more went and bought some
physically bought some from GNC I've
been using the products for 6 months
before they came on on board uh they're
third party tested for ban substances
NSF informed Sports certified so if
you're in the UFC if you're in the NFL
you can trust what's in the bottle you
don't have to worry about getting tested
this is the best of the best no colors
or flavors from artificial sources
what's on the label is on the freaking
label period they have patented key
ingredients never generic Alternatives
like most supplement companies do
they're pure calf organic caffeine
instead of synthetic caffeine is so much
better for you it's a longer Buzz as
well um my favorite product is the
mindset when you talk about getting
focused you talk about if whether you're
going into a meeting you're doing a
workout uh you just want to not be bored
out of your mind talking to your
girlfriend dude get on that mindset but
the the mindset Elite it's it it has the
gold labeling on it it is unreal the
Pre-Workout Elites I'm telling you dude
I think you're going to lift 100 more
pounds okay I can't prove that but I'm
telling you be stronger all right the
they work and the science speak for its
freaking self I guarantee you're going
to feel a difference when you use cage
product um they're for you if you're
ready to train harder live healthier
become the strongest version of yourself
all right uh these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration this product is not
intended to diagnose treat cure prevent
any disease if you're buying suppl for
that stuff you're stupid go to cage.com
that's K aeed d.com use the code sha for
20% off that means 20% off the
Pre-Workout Elite hydration Elite their
protein powers are ridiculous their
mindset Elite all that you get 20% off
go to cage K aed.com promo code is sha
for 20% off I'm telling you try it it's
a game changer
caged nice thanks Chen you're welcome
Chen are you excited for the live firing
the
kid a hell yeah dude I mean I'm I'm
we're doing a resiny in Austin me and
Brian K if you haven't heard we're doing
live R see it's one one night a month
okay one night a month let's not get
crazy one night I don't want to travel
as much so this is what we agreed to
it's one night a month okay it's at
10:00 it's at the Vulcan the stepmother
ship Vulcan gas company um that's off
Sixth Street there in Austin where
there's a ton of homeless okay but you
work your way around them you'll see the
venue and we're doing a live firing the
kid podcast not stand up with me and
Brian you know Main Event co-main Event
no no live podcast live fighting the kid
fan interaction fan questions we'll have
you submit your questions on the fireing
the kid account we'll pick our top 10
then we're doing live questions from the
audience it's going to be a grand old
time one show to start off one show only
one night that's February 15th in Austin
Texas Brian K and me live podcast firing
the
kit should be a good time the whole gang
will be there hopefully Casey's not sit
now who's the stickler I'm need you to
drive me to Austin carpool can you
imagine I remember going to the first
one this is before I knew you guys I
went to Irvine it was such a fun time
you had fun I'm
glad I've been here that's that's every
guy you had fun hell yeah good good
that's good to good glad you had a good
time good to see you have a good night
it's a great time it is a good time I
can't wait me and Brian haven't been
together in a hot second I mean we did
uh co- headlining at Cina in a the laugh
Factor but as far as like a podcast just
a different vibe yeah it's funner
because we're together you know that's
how we started silly goose time so we're
going back to that we got a very special
guest as well big guest y'all might know
him I say that right now y'all might
know him so we'll have special guests
there behind the scenes it's going to be
fun me and Brian getting back together
man it should be fun it should be a lot
of fun mixing with that your boy is a
truck racer I race trucks I'm getting
ready for the mint 400 I leave Friday to
go test drive the truck they built for
me so should be interesting and I did
tell them I flip my DRX so I need
lessons not going to lie to you but yeah
that's uh second week of March but I'm
i' I've been getting rearing up for it
test driving the car rigid uh made this
special car so truck so it should be
interesting I can't wait my brother's my
co-pilot co-driver you know the guy goes
right left right left that's J those are
freaky when I watch those like rally
those they look so crazy it's going to
be about an8 hour race I'm going to [__]
my pants so you're you're getting
trained first and then you're going to
race I've been training I've been
training yeah yeah I just don't tell you
guys good luck yeah I know that looks
insane okay you should be
fun what's this so Rampage Jackson
announ his boxing debut against former
heavyweight champion Channon breaks
about time yeah they've been talking
back and forth going for this forever
and they're also kind of like homies but
they've been each other yeah so
apparently that's contract is signed
that's a video it's not a big deal but
uh yeah when is it I love I don't think
they actually gave a date I love Rampage
I can't wait for that oh never mind hold
on June June 1st okay we had some time
um I love this from uh Kayla Harrison
she goes I don't believe in cutting
weight when I saw him like oh that's not
good she has a lot of weight to cut but
she doesn't she walks around like even
when she was competing at 145 she walked
around like 150ish like she doesn't she
just lives that life when I found out
I'm like I feel a little better about
her fight against Holly home cuz she be
walk around like 140ish you know she
have to cut the last few pounds
but that's good when I saw her I was
like oh my God she's so she's the Brock
Lesnar female MMA yeah that's good then
yeah I'm rooting for her man I'm a big
fan oh I think even with that um that
fight I think Holly Holmes said if she
if Kayla doesn't make weight that she
most likely won't fight so hopefully
Kayla does make weight no I wouldn't
either I'm Holly if she comes in like 15
pounds over hey man yeah
um we talked about this before where Jim
Miller really wants for the UFC 300
fight for him Bruce said he's down if
the UFC officials sanction it UFC's like
hey man we're more high class than that
we can't have you cuss in the Octagon
like hey dude it's cage fighting also
you guys do slap fighting let him say
the f word right yeah I mean that's such
a special occasion for someone like UFC
300 you got to
yeah so that's what I saw
online and this is from champ. RDS
and it's from John Morgan
apparently this this comment this girl
goes I don't think people really care
all that much come on dude you're a
casual it's everything
dumbass that should be the title episode
you're a casual everything dumb Uh Kevin
Lee he's retired for 6 months he's
saying he wants to come back he got
bored yeah I'm coming out of retirement
I'll fight MMA again I don't know when
where who yet but I'm dropping weight
and getting into shape now I'm going to
get in the best shape of my life Focus
right now it's been six months since I
retired I miss being around the sport
yeah let it do it
dude the heart grows
fonder not for you though right what
it's not for you though I will fight you
right now you don't want to go back in
right no no but I also but I have a lot
going like like Kevin Lee is such a
talent and he you know he he has
potential be World Champ he's still
young I have other ways to put my energy
into things you know yes I'm racing
trucks
chin I don't have time to find 3,000
podcasts racing trucks yeah you got lotu
kids I got standup I got podcast I got a
lot going on I'm we didn't even talk
about it because uh I was having issu
with my baby daughter I'm the
commentator for uh game bread knuckle
yeah and your first show first show
coming up in March right uh yeah I think
yeah it's March Yeah March is busy
that's going to be dope dude yeah that
should be fun um what was I say oh that
Kevin Lee's brother who knew would have
known you know Keith Lee who is also a
fighter I think he fought in Bellator
maybe or something like that but he
became this enormous Superstar like on
Tik Tok doing food reviews Keith Lee did
Keith Lee that's Kevin Le's brother I
didn't know that yeah huge Superstar on
Tik Tok you never know man you never
know so uh shamat car Sandu posted this
picture of Nick Diaz I I don't know
where this is maybe at the UFC but it's
at the Apex yeah is that the Apex but
then a lot of fans the Apex says
nobody's there to so that could be it
but a lot of fans are commenting on this
specific thing on his hand and saying
like he has staff could be staff or got
bit by homeless guy and he's looking I
don't know what do you think man he he
look you know what I think chin looks
rough he looks rough who knows maybe
just rolled up and was like what is this
and now like get a fight he's like at
the Apex like yeah come on in he's like
all right my hands has an open moon but
I'll check it out you know he I mean
he's also a fighter like he's had a
rough life man yeah don't be mean to him
who knows what he's dealing with no I
know you're trying to bully him right
now and I don't appreciate not at all
not at all um I don't think he's
fighting GSP after seeing this picture I
mean I don't think GSP wants to fight
him that's what he says that's what he
keeps saying fake news oh I I just want
your thoughts on this Daniel Cory said
if they if UFC this is by the way this
is just like you know who knows if this
ever happened s but if the UFC ever made
a 165 division uh Conor McGregor should
be in there for the title I know what
this is DC's like me you had it your
content creator and it's slow week so
you come up with [__] like this that's
what I do with GSB fighting Nick Diaz I
was like I have nothing to talk about
check this out that's all it is kind of
a slow week there's no doubt about that
at all that's all it is but yeah Conor
165 would be amazing they should
definitely immediate like title 100% all
right fight for the title and then we're
still waiting on the news if you're UFC
fan Dana says say the 300 Main Event
going to blow your mind the card is
going to blow your mind nothing he's
announced yet has blown our mind and he
knows that that dude has ear to the
ground he even though I can't hear that
well he has his ear to the ground you
know so what I'm wondering what the
fight's going to be the rumor is and
pretty good rumor here and I this what
the kids are saying around the cooler
it's Alex Pier versus um our boy Tom
Aspen for the heavyweight championship
and Alex is gonna go for the only three
belt Champion three Division champion
you're telling me that's not tasty that
would blow my mind yeah that would yeah
if Dan is trying to get me to bust that
will do it you feel me it'd be tough not
and I love Tommy asol I love fellow
Englishman I love Tommy he's one of my
favorites if not definitely favorite
heavyweight I love Tom but a part of
he's really rooting for Alex to be the
first ever three Division champion it
will never be done again your witness in
history that's not UFC 300
worthy yeah that's that'll blow your
mind and as much as we love that will
twist your dick in a notot even if it
was stal Bender versus drus that doesn't
do it no they've they've announced that
remember that fight was supposed to
happen we went all right yeah huh if
it's Strickland dupes again that didn't
blow our mind we're we're like okay this
would blow our mind this would blow your
mind if he announce he me out here if
you want to bust your nut if Dana wants
to blow you off right blow your mind if
he announce Alex Pi Tom aspal
300 you did it Daddy and then if you
went also Conor McGregor lyanna
Edwards what why not all I
mean you want your mind blown that would
do it
yeah anything with Conor for case and me
but dude Conor Leon yeah and not any
right to do to our boy B M upop I'm not
saying that but I'm here to make money
I'm here to get views Connor Leon Tommy
Aspen Alex
B Main Event co-main Event mind blown
would Connor do a
CO good question I don't think he would
do a he wouldn't so you would do Conor
Leon Edwards Tommy Aspen and Alex pier
and Chin just rammed his teeth onto the
mic that's how crazy it is you rammed
your teeth onto the mic that would do it
name another fight I can mention where
you'll Ram your teeth on your mic no
Alex and Tom without a doubt but that's
and that's com event you announced
Connor
Leon wait so that would also make Connor
a triple champ no so it's God I'm losing
all energy body double triple chance you
in the Co in the Main Event co-main
Event you have two gentlemen and they're
going to be big underdogs but if they
pull it off you have the for the first
time ever two two triple crown
Champions that would blow your mind
you're welcome UFC I'm sick of running
the marketing
team insane right yeah just take my
money right yeah you would do it
absolutely chin you would do it 100%
yeah double triple champ triple triple
champ 300 will never happen again will
never ever happen again
it'd be historic you have two guys but
the chance of them winning is not good
don't worry about that yeah we're not
worried about that it were just the
possibilities there yeah that's your UFC
300 Main Event co-main
Event it's
happening did I start it here I don't
know dude but UFC you're welcome that
would be incredible that's it if you
want to blow your mind those are the
only fights you can make the only fights
UFC can make for UFC 3 to knock our
dicks in the dirt is Tommy asol aier
co-main event Connor Leon Edwards Main
Event the and then think about the rest
of the card it's tasty rest card like
dude this thing's fun but it's not
mind-blowing you have those two and that
insane lineup that's UFC 300 worthy name
two other fights they can make that
would actually com complete
that there you can't no you're going to
Wiki yeah I'm just seeing what they're
so far
but the computer's very slow right
now right now there's nothing where
you're like oh I have to see it's good
really good it's tasty but they've also
been giving us crap lately but this is
so tasty
dude so good now imagine you're staring
at your screen right now Jen and those
wear glasses and pop up co-main event
Main Event cuz right now you don't have
a co- or me right now you have a that's
a fun card but you want UFC 300 worthy
dude two guys going for Triple Crown
Champions UFC 300 you think the three is
just a coincidence oh wow okay see going
see where I'm going mhm see where I'm
going see where I'm going you guys like
it you buying this if you're in the
meeting room right now you going if
you're D you're going I like it we'll do
it we'll do it are you doing it
Chen I'm doing it as long as they do it
they got to do it yes they do it again
right it's tasty that's your UFC 300
Main Event co-main Event you're welcome
that's the end of the
show that's it all right good I can't
beat that and fire on the kid live
Austin yeah that's right I'm glad you
brought that up speaking of Triple Crown
Champions fireing the kid is back
together it's a live pod in Austin Texas
at the the stepmother ship the Vulcan
it's Brian C and myself one show only 1
p.m. February 15th it's a Thursday night
let's get weird Austin tickets
at fatz.com all right kids love you
let's sell this [__] out find the kid
Army let's ride UFC 300 triple Champion
three not a coincidence it's happening
you're welcome like subscribe love you
guys I'm
out